Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Spime
A game by Suits 'n Nukes who made all those other weird and wacky and
far-out-there games that we've played in the past.
uhh
They seem to be able to crank out games very quickly
But this is supposed to be a different experiment.
More... ethereal. Or etherEEEal as I love to prounounce
Or, or not ethereal, that's the wrong word anyway.
Whatever. (Game: I'm so glad I came out tonight.)
[Game:] It's getting late though. I better make a stop to the restroom real quick before hitting the road.
[Mark:] Oh, okay. Also may I note that the specific art style
that this game developer has... it's just a little off-putting in general.
Oh, that's actually nice. Oh, this is lovely.
Which way am I supposed to go? HELLO?
Thank you for the pancakes
Thank you for the pancakes.
Why are you wrapped up in a blanket? Are you OK?
Hello?
*suspiciously* Alrighty then. Carrying on. Staff only...
Hi- oh GOD!
Why is everyone in these games so creepy?!
Even the PENGUINS were creepy! And the penguin was a murderer...
Oh. There we go.
*click* Hello?
Ah.
This is mildly disconcerting.
Uh, okay.
*giggling slightly* My, my reflection moves at slightly the wrong pace as I do.
And also there's a note on the wall. Do I need that?
Alrighty then. Don't mind me!
oooookay
*zip*
*sfx urination*
Okey dokey then.
I keep expecting something to happen...
It just seems like something's gonna happen.
Oh, don't worry about washing your hands! No hygiene here!
Can I click on that then?
Oh!
[Game:] What's this? Some kind of note? I wonder who left it?
[Mark:] I'm not yet sure what has happened.
Every time I try to leave this diner, I end up right back inside.
I'm leaving this note as proof to myself, proof that I can't possibly be returning to the same space.
It's hard to imagine even writing this.
I know how "moving around" works. One foot in front of the other, same as it's always been,
*irritated* So why the hell am I not going anywhere?!
*rustle* Well, I dunno, you tell me. Was that me writing that note?
Is that my reflection writing that note? Something's going on here...
Something's a little funky!
Ah.
Okey.
Oh.
Alrighty then, I guess I won't go that way.
*running, panting* HELP!
YOU! I can't click on you...
Anybody here? Hello?!
eh eh eeh eh
AHH! I dunno...
Wait, whoa! The person in the blankets is gone but the blanket is still there...
*suspiciously* Why are they there...?
Okay... Are you also trapped here?
*door opening* Oh!
[Game:] What's happening? Am I going crazy or something? ([Mark:] Oooohhh...)
[Mark:] I get it!
[Game:] Hello? Can anyone hear me? ([Mark:] Hello?)
[Mark:] Is anybody- whoo. That's weird.
*unnerved* Hi?
*spooky music plays in the background*
Okay, enter the kitchen, alright... why am I in here?
Do I need anything from here? Do I need some tools... for some reason?
Okay, the blankets are eeeeeey...
Alrighty then...
Uh, a little disturbing... still don't know what's going on!
Okay, I- gwhaaay, that's weird!
Oh jeez. I'm looking at the painting on the wall back there.
Seems to be an odd... odd piece of art choice.
*child giggling creepily*
*nervously* Hi?
Who's there- oh, God...
Oh, jeez... *even creepier music starts playing*
Okay...
*child giggles again, whooshing noise*
HOKAY... I'm going to pretend like that piss-demon didn't
just come out of the piss dimension and then... haunt my dreams...
*nervous* Don't mind me, just gonna... do my thing...
In here... alone... forever apparently...
Alrighty then, so what is this? *click*
*cheery piano music starts playing as device whirs* [Device:] Interdimensional Travel and You.
Hello, and welcome to the exciting world of Interdimensional Travel!
It can be pretty exciting to wander the mysterious landscapes of the multiverse.
But, it can also be dangerous!
Remember to always follow the Interdimensional Rules and Regulations
when passing between possibility scapes.
To begin instruction, insert tape *TWO* now.
*cheerful music fades, device stops whirring*
I don't have tape 2, do you have tape 2?
I don't know where tape 2 would be... *spooky music begins again*
Alright, I'm just gonna carry on being lost... and looping back and forth forever  I assume...
I'm just gonna check... aha, hello.
[Game:] Another note. Wonder what it says?
[Mark:] Well, I'm gonna read it. After what I just saw,
I'm not even sure what's REAL anymore. Are you still there, yellow child?
*quietly* Am I still here...?
I don't know what "here" is. I don't know what "there" is.
I don't know where we are... I don't know where anything is... *door opening noise*
Alrighty then... *scratchy feedback noise*
OOOOOOOOHHH. ([Game:] What the heck is that thing?! I'd better find somewhere to hide, fast!)
DEEEHHH, OKAY! *noise continues loudly*
Alrighty then, I'll hide in heeeeeere... *click*
*feedback noise stops, cheerful music begins again* [Device:] Tape *TWO*.
Fundamentals of moving through the multiverse.
Imagine an ant, crawling across a sheet of paper. ([Mark:] Okay...)
We can think of the paper as representing a plane of existence, and the ant is us.
Technology has finally progressed to the point where it is now possible to connect different planes of existence.
The same way we can connect two or more sheets of paper.
*cheerfully* Just as the ant moves from page to page, you too can travel from existence to existence!
Insert tape *THREE* for more information.
[Mark:] I... *music fades, device stops*
Ermeh amneh... *confused noises*
I'm not fully following you. There was a weird meat monster that assembled out of nothingness
outside this hallway, and I'm assuming that these lines are marking how many times I've been here...?
*creepy music begins again* But apparently I don't remember it until just now?
So I guess I'm just gonna get outta here...
Is it gonna kill me?
Is it still there?
Oh! *whoosh*
Gotta hold it... yeah, cover your face, that's a good idea.
Okay, just gonna... oh, there it is! *relief*
Okay. Well. Hi.
Weird... interdimensional... green sweating...
Did you drink your Gatorade
Alright I'm outta here. *scared noises*
Okay then. *door noise*
*sarcasm* Oh. Good. The artwork is even better than before. I'm so glad...
Hi meat monster! Welcome back to this plane of existence!
Oh, God. There's no more tutorial machine.
Oh boy. *door noise* Yeah, nothing here.
Okay, I guess I gotta go out to the meat monster which is... okay, it just turned around, so if I go
♫ Quickly now, quickly now, quickly now. ♫ ♫ Quickly, quickly quickly... ♫
Quiggly! Quiggly quiggly.
Hrp! Woah-hey-oooh.
You didn't see me, didya? Ya didn't see nothin... eugh...
*loud creepy moaning noise*
Okay... EUUUWWAAY!
*screech as monster notices Mark*
Euuuuuuu. Okay then! Awrighty!
Can I get another note, please? Or do I have to die- oh, there we go.
Haah. Here I go, leaving marks, scribbling notes, how long have I been doing this again?
How long am I capable of doing this? Just delirious. Need to get a grip. Need to keep going.
Can't stop... can't stop...
So is this- *Mark interrupted by monster spawning*
Is, is that another meat monster or is that coming in here?
*pulsing rhythm*
Okay.
Alrighty then.
So that's... goood...?
Don't know? Okay, so I've gotta exit while it's just about not there...
Oh, you, yeah, okay. Here we go. *demonic seahorse noises*
Okay, where's the other one? Is that the only one? I don't think that's the only one, is it?
Okay, it's the only one, okay. You're not gonna kill me this time!
Oh hey, Grim Reaper. How're ya doing? Good to see you again.
Alright, just gonna go in here. Hope for another tape on interdimensional travel that's gonna
tell me all the things. I gotta admit, it's an interesting concept, and it's a bit...
bit panicking to know... I'm probably gonna die...
Hi. Again, welcome to this plane of existence.
Okay, he's gonna go that way... oh shit.
Okay. Herpaderbader, mmmh.
Oh. I just noticed the guy in that painting looking at me so deliriously.
He, uh... is really interested in what he sees.
Oh, there's another note over there, I gotta get that before I get outta here.
Okay, hi. Hello. Ho- urgh. *low drone plays again*
Ah!
That's no bueno.
Why do you have a- *creature makes strange groaning sound* eurgh. Gross.
Just gonna... meander this way.
EEEEHHH. Whooo!
Okay. I had a run-in with the yellow child once more. This time, I grabbed him. An easier task than I would have
imagined previously. It was upon this seizure that the facade fell away and I learned of his true nature.
"Simon" as he likes to go by, is not of this world. That is, as I learned before he once again disappeared, he is of
this world, only of another dimension. In a strange way, the likes of which I cannot fully explain, I feel as if I
already knew that. I must press on. I must be on the right track.
Well, I didn't see anybody! Who are you talking about, and *quietly* why is he just standing there?
Eww. I dunno what it is with it's cross-sectional butthole mouth.
I don't... no.
You don't smell nothin'.
That's right, turn around. What are you doing?
*spooky scary butthole mouths*
*very very quietly* Hyuuuuuuuu...
HABOOSKY!
OOOOOOOOOOHH! You thought you were gonna get something and you didn't!
Alrighty then. *monster purrs*
Oh, it's just a kitty kat! It wants to be petted, it's purring so nicely...
Alrighty then.
Anything else in here?
Oh hello. *Oh, hi Mark!*
I've recovered a device that details the monster. These flying *spaghetti* meat-balls as I have been referring to them, at this point.
Are known as *assholes* quantum keepers. A rose by any other name, it should seem. *breath*
Regardless of what you want to call them. They spell death any way you slice it. *How can they spell? They don't have hands. Budumtiss!*
I will continue to avoid these quantum keepers. Atleast until when or perhaps if a better way reveals itself.
If they do come to dissolve to their dark matter state, if the PLD unit I recovered is to be believed,
upon absorbing a "paradox" then, I, perhaps I can come to use this to my adavantage. *I know run-on sentence but blaim the game not me. Also confused Mark*
I didn't understand a word of any of that. *Its okay Mark you will. In time. Wink, wink*
anything in here to help me how long am
I gonna be looping through the hole
hi again it's where you going which way
you gotta go
sassy bitch oh come on don't do nothing
to me is you getting goop on my pants
maybe bit of doom ok
oh thank you the familiar faces of
friends always good good as account the
hash marks on the wall 46 in total i
find i'm jumping randomly assuming i'm
following a line along the likes of me
who's left notes as well as occasionally
being interlaced with the me who has
chosen to not leave notes given the
progress I can only conclude the path if
there indeed is a path is random at best
I found little to no coherency no
numerical or structural rhyme and reason
I find only that every time across
through the exit door
the only true option left to me I return
to the same diner
I'll be it ever so slightly altered
sometimes altered in ways i cannot
imagine but accepting the rarest of
occasions different from any I
Ben do before I fear I'm losing my mind
ok this is really interesting because
it's like a layering of layering of like
different realities that you could go
through and also there's no there's no
orbital dude a door over there this time
so what does that mean is there anything
in Arizona am I just gonna be looping
forever
is there anything here oh god dammit
archives gotta run from this one okay
holy shit oh well as it returns a fun
enough but habit haha keeps popping in
and out of existence size of a six or
seven-year-old taunts me
finally something seems to be able to
see an answer me i get a petulant little
brat made of lighter startups or
something
ok then that didn't help me at all ok
gotta go gotta go we and my dad that
things were later I don't think there's
a save mechanic so I don't know how he's
gonna handle it
first off if it was nothing like I've
ever experienced in my life one moment I
felt my bits and bobs scattered about
drunk as a skunk and then like it never
happened sober as a judge
vaguely recall reading the alcohol
stores why not right
flying meatballs of death circling
around the place never-ending
unexplainable diner atmosphere yellow
children made of drugs hallucinations
then like it never happened to push the
door and there I am completely reset
here
azhar this gotta be something here
it's gotta be something waiting for me
to discover it right maybe not maybe not
at all
gotcha ok what the fuck happened
you're the cause of all this are you
gonna tell me what's going on right now
leave me alone let me tough guy huh
we'll see about that we'll see about
what am i doing i'm not gonna give him a
swirly I'm gonna give him a swirly our
night
well i'm gonna give him a swirly this
tell me everything you're really gonna
get to find the one who let me go
I warned you may need
just gonna drown them oh no whoa the one
who hit of course of course I'm been so
blind
it wasn't a question of where but when
it's so obvious now what are you talking
about what's going on
where am I go through the back door
just one more time I'll explain
everything to you there but hurry the
keepers are coming
what the fuck happened when I get old
you like some shine some light into my
mouth and I'm quickly and old important
of interdimensional safety laws and
regulations ok order to maintain down
between planes of existence
that's all in forces commonly referred
to as quantum people are dispatched to
nullify any paradoxes that around the
sole purpose of the creatures is to
track down any paradoxical entity that
it presented itself within a looping
time step
any threat eliminated they simply fade
from a system and convert to Dark Matter
state until relieved called on again
repeating the cycle as necessary
no frightening here the quantum keeper
plays a crucial role in protecting
against paradox that may otherwise
spread to surrounding planes of
existence and restore order to the
multiverse
ok fifth dimensional travel 101 as a
user of 5p technology your capabilities
for passage and beyond our dimensional
step to lower levels of existence think
back to the idea of a man traveling
along a sheet of paper imagine now if
the paperwork we rolled up so that both
ends are now touching as the end news
from one end of the sheet for the next a
loop is created inhabitants existence
are bound to the sheet out their forms
are covered by the mountain
la fifth dimensional travel however you
are free to process to any point on any
place at any given such freedom we
convert with profit as failure to act
within the safety guidelines to disrupt
not only the currently occupied
possibilities based put rupture ejection
planes of existence as well causing
great rift echo across the infinities
fear traveled with caution
good god why would anybody be given the
responsibility to do that just be able
to cross across dimensions and then
interact with all the other universes in
this universe my god thats that's
branching into concepts of spine again I
don't know what spy means avoiding
paradigm ok our actions of
interdimensional travelers and echo
unforeseen consequences across the
farthest reaches of infinity therefore
we must read careful setting into motion
any event that can alter the course of
other plane of existence
remember the care and maintenance of the
world and their inhabitants is everyone
with possibility
referred to the handbook the do's and do
not do of interdimensional travel
I get it with your thumb for more
information all I get it
I'm not the interdimensional traveler
that thing was I thought it was about me
the whole time no I'm the aunt in the
equation where the ant we're not being a
dimensional traveler where the and
that's being bounced into over and over
again and that was rolled up into a loop
like that analogy wasn't just a metaphor
its literal example what's happening
here and I don't know its prime means
good i'm assuming it's not the game is
now ready for part two
click this message to open part 2 after
clicking give it a second you may need
to allow access the same way you didn't
part 1
alternatively if this process fails and
crashes you can download each part
separately from the game page
oh no ok we are world-renowned oh that's
not good
well I way away away away away away i'm
guessing you've got me spotted and I
gotta get going
so what would happen if i wait wow whoa
hello that paradox is now to add wanna
just go close the other one
well shit man you know I'm gonna go into
the get your baby can i hide well i
gotta can't hide of two old right now
for real right I'm going for it
freedom and also i do realize that's the
old guy that was in the blanket in the
beginning of the game i do remember that
i do one hundred percent remember that
and I can't go in there anymore
hey you don't look so good aren't you
taking Julie he come over here for just
a second
huh Oh what is it Tom do we still have
that Blake in lost and found the red 1i
think so yeah could you go grab that and
bring it over to offer in here looks
like you could use it
sure thing why do you have a seat here
the booth I'll be right back i'm dead
now can you hear me ok sir george's you
had a fall back there why don't you rest
anything just let us know
take all the time you huh
hi that's right i'm surprised you
recognized me without my head inside of
a toilet
I'm sorry I was just so scared and I
know I'm the one who should be sorry
none of this was your fault you're
simply caught up in something I was
doing and for that
well I guess we both kinda screwed at I
don't understand maybe this will clear
things up
remember this don't worry only you can
see me
that's is that me in a way I'm not like
you you know where I come from for all
possibilities exist all I and not at all
i don't know next to understand your
kind simply can't but i might come to
realize I'm AWD state and i must spend
the rest of what you call forever fixing
that mistake you're you're going to be
doing this forever
no silly just her what you call forever
forever is not as long as you think it
is but that's not for you to understand
not now anyway
well I ever understand all the top and
here maps time but right this second
wouldn't you rather leave this place
alright yes then go out the front door
this time go before you end up leaving
out the back again go
you are the one who leaves ok
whoopsie-doopsie dupe see all which way
am I going now all but the Bombardier
off-pump such i'm such a goof
I'm such a gosh-darn goof well nevermind
i can't go that way alright then well I
got misguided I'm so old
what's really interesting is I was in
that paradox universe for both forever
and not at all to me like it might as
well have not been noticeable it was
like an endless loop
Wow wait so I'm young again when i go
out
huh
ok so all right let me read let me wrap
my head around all this because this is
getting a little complicated here so we
were in that Universal was in like the
analogy a loop with that and we were the
end but the guy the interdimensional
travel was bounding around wherever he
goes and every time he bound in he
disrupted things and cause things to
reset and that he contained this diner
in that loop so that every time we go
around it
everything would be exactly the same and
yet totally different as he hit it and
went by so we as the person trapped in
there was both everyone at once going
through it for all that time forever
that we were in there and at the same
time we were the one that leaves because
it was all occurring at the same time
because the way time was loose so it was
one unit and one moment but it took a
lifetime get what I'm saying
see the way that whatever i'm not gonna
be I'm not probably not even explaining
it correctly but either way that was
interesting that was really interesting
and I like the thought experiment of it
like other interdimensional travelers
accidentally fucking up your entire
existence just going poop
my bad and then like what do you take
from that you don't remember any of it
because it never occurred but you were
changing it as it goes by you were the
one that changed it and you were the one
experiencing the changes all once
because not only you made the change in
one moment but that one moment spread
across the entirety of all the changes
do you know what that like do you
understand what I'm saying there you are
not one you are all and then all is just
one
ok anyway I'm done anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this I certainly did this is
really cool i like it definitely a
departure from the other like the one
thing this guy makes is really David
Mills
is really varied subjects and really
very types of games and I can definitely
appreciate that so let me know what you
thought of this down the comments below
if you got some other opinions about it
and you think I'm wrong I'm definitely
willing to hear it put it down the
comments as well thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video, BYE-BYE!
*Outro music*